I love this movie so much as someone who
grew up watching classic musicals and
dreaming of moving to LA and love and
ambition and dreams I know you didn't
just make it for me but it feels like
you did you're welcome this is all just
amazing I appreciated when you got the
script did you feel that way like this
is perfect for you it was definitely
intriguing and you know magical it
looked very magical but it was also a
lot of talking to Demian the writer
director and just kind of you know
exploring what what this was going to be
ultimately because it was such a huge
ambitious vision when it came to the
singing and dancing and playing piano
how much does it help having someone by
a side that you know so well that you
have that comfort level with Emma yeah
we were so lucky to have made two films
together beforehand because there was a
lot to do in this movie a lot of work a
lot of preparation and we were just able
to hit the ground running there's so
many themes I think everyone can relate
to because even though it has the songs
and dances and the big numbers it does
have those relatable themes to it I do
think it's something that is a very kind
of universal dream to have the luxury of
pursuing your dream so it was it was
nice to make a film about that I
understood what it felt like to be a new
artist that's trying to make it I
understood what it felt like to be
rejected and you know there's other
competition that's trying to do the same
thing you're doing and I really
identified with that aspect of the film
what kept you going part of its just the
audacity of believing in yourself and
knowing you have something special to
offer and I think every artist that
really succeeds has to have that sense
of audacity like I'm good they just
don't know it yet what is it like when
you are on set and you're surrounded by
all the extras and they're all in
costume and they're all dancing it's
surreal for the most part it's pretty
surreal I love dance more than anything
I think it's my favorite art form so to
watch people you know dancing very like
professional dancers really tearing it
up is like just literally my favorite
thing to watch can we end then to be
with some jazz hands yeah
yeah now I can pretend I've been in the
musical with you
[Music]